what do screenwriters need to know about
timelines
yeah i mean i think that there's
definitely um
it's worth paying attention to the
timeline of your story because there's a
certain
flow that when you're reading a script
if
that if the if the sort of flow of logic
or our sense of how much time is passing
in the story if that is off
or you know unclear that can be
disorienting and can make
reading it confusing so definitely worth
paying attention to
um it's it's not a problem i see that
often
but occasionally it does come up where i
can't figure out
so if this event happened then how much
time has passed you know so
um i think that goes to clarity which is
one thing that you're always striving
for in your script is
conveying as clearly as possible exactly
what
you know exactly what the story is
what's happening so that we can
understand
kind of the you know the journey that
you're taking us on yeah i think it's
hard too when there's like
they're jumping back and forth in
someone's memory or
they're they're showing different
people's realities and so that timeline
becomes blurred but
yeah i'm not sure the best way to convey
that um
are you are you working different
timelines into your librarian story
we could we could try that yeah okay so
if we were gonna use that i know people
are gonna be like okay move on with a
librarian but
if we let's suppose we wanted the
librarian to think
back to growing up and maybe
the perfect boy that her parents wanted
her to marry and
she just didn't want that she wanted
somebody that had more
edges around them so she kind of maybe
he was like the local
business owner son he was like the
perfect guy on paper
but there was nothing there for her yeah
and then she remembers like
the bad kid and having a crush on this
guy and so
that takes her back now to being 35
and working in this you know city
library
and she's regarded amongst her peers
but she still has something for this
yeah sort of rough around the edges
writer who's a little bitter and arms
cross and challenges her
but she likes that yeah well i have a
couple of thoughts about this story
so um no so i think it's great so um so
i would say
you're um you are sort of talking about
flashbacks right which is a
which is a topic worth talking about um
i think that
flashbacks you can use i know a lot of
people say don't use flashbacks that are
you know outlawed or whatever you can
totally use flashbacks if we need that
information to understand
the story that we're watching in the
present time you know what i mean
um if it gives me context that i need
in order to appreciate understand
feel whatever the story is that you're
telling me right now
then i think it's valid um i would say
in that case i don't necessarily need to
know that she had a crush on a bad boy
in her childhood in order to understand
the attraction to the bad boy today
right because i think that's a pretty
common thing
pretty common trope for romances right
that women
like bad boys so i would say because
everyone already gets that you don't
have to explain it to us by saying she
had this past
that where she had a crush on a bad boy
um also
just in general i would say with romance
stories um try to keep
just one love interest unless you have
unless they're directly competing right
and so you have like a sort of a love
triangle or something like that
um which is very common as well but if
if we're introduced to someone else that
she was in love with and then now we're
supposed to invest in her being in love
with this person
that can get a little bit muddy and sort
of divide our
our loyalties like who do we want her to
be with right which is exactly the
effect that you want with a love
triangle but in this instance you're not
you're not talking about a love triangle
you're talking about
a backstory that is informing her
um romantic ideal today right right yeah
yeah i was just thinking so that
wouldn't really be a competing timeline
that's more just
just a memory like a flashback sequence
right i mean i think that um there
there definitely are stories that maybe
could be told in parallel timelines
right
and if we're going to take the librarian
example one step further so maybe there
is
a um maybe there is a timeline of when
she was 10 years old and
i i don't know actually i don't think
there is but okay i was gonna say
in some stories there are parallel
timelines or you know
uh two different sort of stories that
are happening in different timelines
um trying to think like the hours i
think was one okay
right do you remember that movie yeah um
it was like three different timelines
in one story and so they chose to do
that i guess the point that i'm making
is
they chose um to tell the story across
different timelines for a deliberate
effect
so that really is the goal before you
make any
um sort of style or structural choices
is understanding what is the effect that
you're trying to have on the audience
um and so then how do i achieve that
effect right so
if i'm trying to um draw out some
mystery about
why she's in love with this guy then
maybe
i want another you know a series of
flashbacks
alluding to some you know romance that
she had years and years ago or something
like that maybe that could be effective
but
but the point being that um i would i
would only make that choice
knowing that i want to have this effect
on the audience i want them to be
curious about how did this woman get to
be this way
and so then that's the effect that i
would be trying to achieve with those
flashbacks does that make sense it does
yeah so maybe she remembers going to the
dance with the good guy
and then she saw the bad boy smoking
outside and amazed like he makes like a
snide comment to her but
there's part of like this he's also like
fishing at the same time and so she kind
of remembers
tommy and his tux or whatever i know i
will say the danger of that and this is
this again goes back to clarity
which is um you have to understand what
your audience is going to see when they
see that flashback
are they going to know that that's a
different bad boy than the one you're
presenting us
with today right so we might be watching
it and going like oh they've met before
she
she actually had a crush on him when she
was a teenager right and that could
change how we understand your story um
it could also just confuse us and
make us wonder like what what is it with
this woman and
this guy i don't know what's happening
with them so that's a good point so
maybe that's too much
backstory could be yeah it could be also
also i will say if you
if you are writing that story and you
want to put that back story in could be
something that you don't need a
flashback for and you can just
get in through you know conversation or
something like that
ah okay maybe like um having drinks with
an old college friend or something
something said right because it feels
like that piece of information is fairly
small
so is it worth stopping the story
flashing back to a completely different
time a completely different cast of
characters except your protagonist
just to let us know that she sort of
always had a thing for bad boys you know
that's something that you can probably
get out in you know a line of dialogue
sure sure like a bartender walks by and
she says like
you know i'll take a martini from him or
something i don't know that's
way too cliche sorry okay
you